aggression from both sides Berlin
deployed more than 1,000 police officers
to keep afd protesters away from their
opponents counter-demonstrators tried to
break through barricades at the sight of
people they suspected word neo-nazis the
police struck back with pepper spray and
batons 5,000 people from across Germany
came to Berlin for the right-wing
anti-immigration afd party rally the
protesters say the country is being
overwhelmed by migrants I'm worried
about our Father then we can't back the
government's migration policies anymore
baha be honest I'm afraid this will turn
out very badly for us Germans had
Berlin's Brandenburg Gate
counter-demonstrators from abroad
alliance of associations and parties had
another message your stream de frutas we
support germany taking in people in dire
situations that's our duty and we intend
to fulfill it organizers from Germany's
mainstream parties as well as the left
and the pirate party had hoped for 5,000
counter-demonstrators but under a
thousand showed up meanwhile the AFD is
attempting to position itself is the
only real alternative to establish
German parties is it young we're here to
protest against Chancellor Merkel's
asylum policies they highlight problems
in Germany that haven't been discussed
for years that's why the AFD is needed
as the sole opposition party the AFD has
the support of eight percent of Germans
that's far from a broad base but still a
number that alarms many people here